my name is Adam a Malak I'm a
neurosurgeon at Cedars Sinai and
director of functional neurosurgery I'm
also one of the co-principal
investigators on a uo1 Roh consortium
studied the neuronal mechanisms of human
episodic memory what I'd like to do
today is give an overview of some of the
methods surgical approaches ethics and
safety related to this project as well
as the field of human neurophysiology
overall so human neural physiology is a
uniquely collaborative effort it
requires expertise from multiple
disciplines typically neurosurgery is
required for putting in electrodes and
removing electrodes as well as having
direct access to the brain surface
neurologists are often required because
of their expertise in managing the
appropriate patients that are clinically
appropriate for these sorts of studies
and of course the expertise of
neurophysiologists and
neuropsychologists in particular
neurophysiologists for collecting and
analyzing the both behavioral data as
well as the neuro physiological data
that we record in our particular lab we
have focused on epilepsy as a model
system a model disease for studying
human neural physiology we choose this
disease because it happens to match from
an experimentalist point of view several
of the requirements that are necessary
for performing these sorts of studies
first of all the most effective
treatment for patients with epilepsy
that is refractory to medication is
surgical removal of the seizure focus
often identifying that seizure focus
requires for clinical reasons to implant
electrodes directly into brain
structures and it turns out that many of
those targets structures are quite
important for normal cognitive
as well thus providing a unique avenue
to study cognitive function and
simultaneously obtain their
physiological recordings in a clinical
setting
finally this monitoring process takes
place over days to weeks providing a
unique opportunity for awake patients to
repeat tasks be in a setting that is
about as close to normal as possible and
allows for good interaction between the
investigators and the patient the system
we're going to be talking about today
and what we use most commonly is what
are called depth electrodes depth
electrodes are small cylinders which
contain electrodes which you can see
space that contacts points throughout
that are implanted directly into the
brain the way we often implant these are
what are called orthogonal trajectories
meaning they go from the outer skull all
the way in toward the middle part of the
brain and you can record from all of
these electrical contacts all the way
out we use what are called hybrid micro
electrodes and macro electrodes which
mean at the tips here there's fine micro
wires which I will discuss a little bit
more in a minute
we then record this signal data on high
quality amplifiers we use laptop
computers for performing behavioral
tasks and we typically we use a keyboard
or a response pad for for responses
particularly a response pad so that the
timing is most accurate one of the
interesting things and as I mentioned
why we use epilepsy because the where we
put these electrodes tends to target
areas that subtend some very important
cognitive functions a subset is listed
here but in the hippocampus and amygdala
issues of memory episodic memory working
memory novelty detection also the
frontal lobes issues of error monitoring
decision-making etc so these are great
cognitive areas that correlate to the
clinically appropriate electrode sites
the basic experimental setup is shown
here basically once electrodes are
implanted a patient is in an epilepsy
Monitoring Unit which is basically a
hospital bed with a camera hooked up to
24-hour EEG monitoring at the same time
preamplifiers on the head are hooked up
into a neurophysiologic in
neurophysiology recording system which
can also record single unit data as
shown here and we get continuous electro
choreography as well we can also put an
eye tracker in place to monitor people
and gaze position and as you can see
from this picture and patients are quite
awake alert and interactive so you
really have a combination set up that
probably most closely mimics what you
would see and let's say a monkey or
rodent set up but with awake behaving
humans that can of course tell us what
they're doing as well as respond to
behavioral tasks we are these are the
micro wires I mentioned earlier so they
come out as a little bundle at the end
of the macro contact this is that are
about 40 micron micro wires and they
allow for the recording of very nice
quality good isolated individual
extracellular action potentials as well
as sometimes multi unit activity as well
as electro choreography and this is just
an MRI image showing some of the typical
targets in the amygdala and hippocampus
one of the important issues in human
neural physiology is that this research
has to be carried out under very strict
ethical guidelines we have to remember
that patients participating in this
research have no direct benefit as a
general rule to the research itself
because as a general rule we are
studying cognitive function not disease
so when we consent patients they must be
very aware of this explicitly aware and
perhaps most importantly we have to make
sure these electrodes are placed for
clinically indicated reasons and not
placed in cognitively interesting areas
that are not
irrelevant simply because even though
the risk of bleeding from an electrode
is low it's not zero and hemorrhage from
an electrode can be devastating
importantly the cost of the electrodes
should be borne by the research team not
the clinical team and patient care is a
priority this experiments are done
within the context of a clinical
environment and clinical issues always
take precedence if a patient has an
issue you always stop the experiments a
patient has the right to refuse at any
point electrodes need to be taken out as
soon as clinical questions are answered
so it really depends on the
investigators to insist on these strict
ethical standards to make sure that the
research can be carried out safely and
appropriately one thing to mention these
hybrid electrodes how safe are they well
we've looked at this question and it
does appear that they are every bit as
safe as standard clinical electrodes
which have a slightly smaller outer
diameter in looking at several hundred
patients the rate of bleeding that
required surgery is very low only two
electrodes total implanted over a period
of approximately 15 years and there have
been no strokes related to this there
are some technical issues but in terms
of safety they appear to be very safe
which is obviously critical it's just an
example of some of the high quality
single unit data that can be recorded it
can be accurately sorted using spike
sorting algorithms to discern various
individual units from a single wire
recording and this has been very well
documented by our group over now many
many years what about the castes we tend
to perform relatively simple tasks and
the criteria are listed below I think
are good guidelines tasks should
generally be simple enough for the
average patient or the average IQ to be
able to do responses should be
relatively easy usually a single
keystroke and of course you should be
recording from a region of interest this
is
simplepass where patients are shown an
image at first there are some there all
new images and a later tap a time point
they're shown a set of new images and
own images and they may be asked a
simple question have you ever seen this
image before a task we can do generally
easily and sometimes we'll add other
other considerations such as which which
quadrant of a screen has been seen or
some other memory related tasks this is
just a simple example some basic data
that can be collected in this method
this is already one of the original
older discoveries by our group this
example of individual neuronal spikes
over a paradigm this is stimulus on
stimulus off and in being shown a set of
images some which are new and some are
old this set of neurons seems to respond
when an image is new and even during a
recall task if it's still a new image
which is the same as a learn cast or an
original you'll have higher firing where
as the image has been seen before then
the firing rate is lower so this is an
example of neurons detecting novelty on
a single trial basis and this is one of
the core observations which has led to a
lot of the other experiments which
you'll hear more about from the other
investigators some of the simple
conclusions for example there are sets
of visually selective neurons that
respond to a specific visual stimulus
but they are not memory selective and
then there are other neurons which seem
to encode whether an image is new or old
a memory for it but don't really care
whether they are what visual category
and as I mentioned the other
investigators will talk much more about
some of these observations to follow so
as part of this uo1
program we have formed the consortium
with other sites to do human neural
physiology there are significant
advantages to a consortium model one of
the problems in human nerve physiology
is the number of patients recorded at
any given site tends to be relatively
low so a single
Center it can take years to acquire
enough data for solid statistically
valid analysis by deploying that same
task across multiple centers that
implant depth electrodes we can
therefore collect much more data from
many more patients more quickly allowing
for more rapid data analysis a secondary
advantage is centers that don't
necessarily have their own deep
neurophysiology program we'll have an
opportunity to develop their own
programs and their own research
questions even if centers use slightly
different methods you can still require
similar data sets and the other thing
that's nice is it fosters nice
collaboration between different groups
with individual strengths as you'll hear
from the other speakers some centers are
better at modeling some groups are
better and data collection some have
expertise at task development and it is
the interaction between all these groups
and disciplines which advances the field
more quickly this is our current
consortium it includes our group here at
cedars-sinai group at University of
Toronto a group at Harvard Medical
School and a group of Johns Hopkins we
may hopefully be expanding the
consortium in the near future to try to
again collect data more quickly this is
a typical example of how a new
behavioral task might be implemented
across a consortium model typically a
single site will develop the tasks that
site will test and verify that tasks
first in normal volunteers they will
then try it out on patients in the
Epilepsy Monitoring Unit to make sure
it's valid and seems to work well they
can then share that the code for running
the task as well as the method with
other consortium methods the data is
then collected across multiple sites and
cooled and then analyzed and then of
course compared with computational
models which can then be used to iterate
toward new tasks and this model we've
been doing for the past three years has
worked very success
and if anything is only gaining steam
and will work better as we go forward
just a couple of closing thoughts human
nerve physiology is a form of research
that can provide fundamental questions
into how the human brain functions this
is unique while animal models have
certain strengths and validity the
ability to ask a person what they are
thinking and doing obviously has
significant advantages and this setup
provides a very strong mechanism for
answering uniquely human brain function
questions collaboration is achievable
and highly rewarding but appears to be
sorely underutilized something we're
working very hard to overcome the fact
that equipment and techniques have
developed so much over the past decade
or more with many more groups involved
now makes this research much more
accessible to many people who might have
shied away from it in the past and
finally basic human research is
fundamental to understanding how the
human brain in specific works and also
for developing therapies to treat
uniquely human disorders such as
disorders of learning and memory
effective response such as autism or
post-traumatic stress disorder and error
processing diseases such as
schizophrenia or obsessive-compulsive
disorder so with that basic summary I'm
going to hand it over to dr. Ely rootage
Hauser my co-principal investigator who
will be addressing some of the work that
is currently ongoing in the lab thank
you Thank You Adam for getting us
started in this come on our panel talk
so I will next talk about some new
insights that we have learned about the
mechanisms of memory based decisions and
I'm speaking here as a representative of
our consortium called neural mechanisms
of episodic memory constituted by the
institutions of which the logos you see
on this
scream so in our consortium we have
taken the approach of studying how
episodic memory works in the human brain
by recording from single neurons in
areas in the medial temporal lobe and
this approach is strongly motivated by
the considerable success that this
approach has had in understanding other
aspects of brain function such as
primary sensory cortex or primary visual
processing as shown on the right on the
slide or more high-level riddle
processing such as in area IT where the
discovery and detailed study of face
cells has led to much new insight into
how vision works so we are taking
motivation from this the success of this
approach to try to understand how human
episodic memory works and in particular
how the different components of the
memory system communicate with each
other and how this activity is
coordinated by means of oscillations and
with the ultimate goal of wanting to
understand how this coordination and the
Emidio components break down in memory
disorders and how we could fix that
breakdown so one of the hypothesis that
we have studied among the consortium is
how memory signals represented in the
hippocampus by the red neurons that you
can see on the Left how those signals
are utilized by other brain areas to
make decisions to inform decisions and
the hypothesis that you can see here is
that they are the blue neuron somewhere
in the brain which are integrators which
integrate memory based signals to inform
choices such as in this case here
whether an image is novel or familiar
and the hypothesis we have investigated
is that one of the areas in the human
formal cortex where such neurons are
present is the medial frontal cortex and
we've recorded from the two areas
indicated here in the slide the pre SMA
and the dACC where each dot is where we
recorded in one particular patient and
this hypothesis is motivated by
a substantial body of animal work in
rodents that indicates that neurons in
these areas phase lock to hippocampal
theta in a transient manner only when
needed for particular behavior so we be
following your hypothesis that this
pathway in humans will be utilized to
make memory based decisions the way we
have investigated this question is by
using a task switching task where we
show patients a sequence of images on
the screen such as shown here the face
and for each of these images the patient
is asked to make a decision and answer
yes or no and in a blocked fashion be
very how what decision the patient is
supposed to make and it varies between a
memory based decision in which it is
have you seen this image before yes or
no or a categorization image decision
where the answer is also yes or no but
it answers questions such as is this
image showing a fruit or is this image
showing a car yes or no and in addition
we are also telling the patient's how to
answer and that's either by you making a
button press while fixating so that's in
the lower row on the left or while not
pressing a button and making eye
movement to the left or the right so
there are four different subsets of
tasks here two different output
modalities and two different cognitive
tasks a memory and the categorization
task for exactly the same visual input
and the same motor of it so the only
thing that changes here is the cognitive
task that the patient is performing and
doing this task one sees something
really remarkable which is that first of
all looking at the well characterized
types of cells in the MTL we find that
these cells are not sensitive to task
demands so in this slide you can see a
cell such as the one on the Left which
encodes something visual this is a human
face cell from these cells one can
decode equally well regardless of the
task that's shown in the middle and most
importantly the code is is generalizable
so what that means is that the decision
play
if one learns position plane in one task
such as the categorization task and then
sees whether it channel eise's with a
memory task it fully generalizes that's
shown on the right plus condition
generalization performance is high this
is remarkably also true for memory
signals so these new old signals such as
the one shown on the left they are
present as expected in the memory task
so that's the right one in the middle
but also during the categorization task
where this signal is not task relevant
but it's still there and this signal is
also there in a fully generalizable
fashion meaning that the decision plane
that distinguishes new from old stimuli
across the neural population of all
recorded neurons is the same between the
tasks so we can train a decoder in one
task and test it in the other this is
the idea that's shown on the lower right
and these memory signals that are shown
here on the left
fulfill all the properties that you
would expect of a memory signal so in
most particularly this memory signal is
continuously strengthened as a function
of the strength of the memory so for
example one of the experiments we have
done on those neurons and those are
shown on this slide here is that this
signal is stronger when the patient
recalls the memory with high confidence
compared to low confidence so you can
see here if the patient says yes I
recognize this image with high
confidence the firing rate of the old
bigger new neural is hired and compared
to when the patient makes the same
decision it's also an old decision and
it's also correct but it's done with low
confidence and indeed what's shown here
on the right on the slide is that these
memory selective neurons carry more
information if the patient retrieves the
image with low with high confidence
compared to low confidence and not shown
here but also critical for those where
this claim is that these neurons
distinguish between false negatives
meaning trials that the patient forgot
but which we know are old and true
negatives meaning there is a remnant of
a memory signal in there and it's thus
not a disease
signal now moving to the medial home
cortex at first sight when mum records
in a media frontal cortex during this
task it looks fairly similar they are
originally selectively neurons such as
shown on the left its neuron increases
firing those two fruits their memory
selective neurons as shown on the right
old pick a new example here but here the
task modulation is very strong so if you
look at the middle panel you see that
the ability to decode new versus old is
much higher in a mediaeval cortex during
the memory tasks compared to the
categorization task and in addition to
being higher is that the neural the
neural representation the geometry of
the neuronal representation changes
considerably so it doesn't generalize
meaning if we train a decoder to decode
new versus old the medial frontal cortex
during the memory task and then tested
in the categorization task that cannot
be done at at levels higher than chance
so that means while the signals are
present in both tasks they are stronger
in one task versus the other and in
addition there they are in a different
format and now I'll talk about in detail
what I mean by that so first of all if
you look at the neurons in the medial
frontal cortex during this sitting task
splits both according to yes and no
which is the answer to decision and the
task we find the remarkable
the remarkable discovery that these
cells are specific to the task so if you
look at the cell - shown here this cell
increases its firing rate when the
answer is yes but only if this if making
this decision required access to memory
was based on the memory it does not
distinguish us from knowing the
categorization task now on the other
hand the outer cell the one shown cell
number one on the left does the opposite
it distinguishes it also signals yes but
only during the categorisation task and
remarkably doing the memory task these
signals are truly choice signals there
are not memory signals and this is shown
on the right this is because
this claim is based on an analysis where
we train a decoder which has 50 percent
correct trials and 50 percent incorrect
trials during which the choice is
different from the ground truth which is
new old and doing this analysis you can
show that these cells signal the choice
regardless of whether it's correct or
not not the ground truth so focusing in
more on those choice cells we find that
the geometry of the representation
changes after changing some instructions
but not after changing other
instructions and specifically the
representation changes only if one
changes between during a memory task
versus a categorization task but not
when changing the output modality so on
the left you see this claim supported by
statistics which is if we change if we
train a decoder which reads out the
choice yes versus no it does not channel
it works very well if trained and tested
in the same task so those are the two
thoughts shown on the top but it does
not generalize meaning the decoding
choice is not possible if the training
and the testing is done in different
tasks meaning the decision plane changes
completely but it's not like oh this
decision plane always changes so as you
can see on the right the decision
playing very well generalizes between
output modalities so that the code was
not sensitive to whether the output was
communicated by a button press or a
saccade so why is that so looking at the
neuronal population activity in two
different ways
illustrate what exactly is happening
here so first of all I'm showing you
here the neural dynamics for es versus
no during the two different tasks in a
dynamic plot where you can see this
activity as a function of time and the
most striking thing that this plot
illustrates is that before if you
compare the left versus the right
trajectories which explain the most
variants across dimension one that
dimension differentiates by task not by
choice so the
complains of yes versus no would be
either between the yellow and the blue
line which would differentiate yes from
knowing the memory task or I'm the same
on the right side meaning this
illustrates that if you fail a decision
plane to one task it will not channelize
the other task and it also illustrates
the fact that the largest amount of
variance here is explained not by choice
but by task so what why does the
decision plane not generalize in some
situations so this is well illustrated
here so what these parts show is the
mean activity in the high dimensional
space but plotted in a dimension rate
reduction reduction English done with
MDS and in the four different conditions
and in the case on the right in the
upper right where a decision plane does
channelize you see that all that happens
when you change the task from using
button-press to saccade is a slight
shift but all the dots of the different
conditions are parallel so if you
imagine a decision plane which is
orthogonal to the plane shown you would
see that the same plane would would
clearly work for both types of paths
this is not true for changing between
memory and categorization task so if you
notice on the lower left the conditions
for example 1 & 2 & 3 they totally
changed position so they are not
parallel meaning if you would fit a
decision plane which establishes yes
from now for the blue plane which would
be also our father' no but you would not
channelize the right one so this is
indeed what we think is happening which
is that when one changes from the
categorization to the memory task a
different subset of the neuronal space
is used by the medial frontal lobe - for
the neuronal dynamics now we also looked
at how this activity propagates from the
hippocampus in the medial formula so
what we did here is we recorded
simultaneously neurons in the medial
frontal cortex that blue dot and a local
field potentials either in the
hippocampus and amygdala the yellow dots
on the left now we looked at spike for
coherence 25 using PPC of individual
neuron
in the medial frontal cortex relic ample
theta and when we compared at baseline
before stimulus is shown the the pattern
of spiteful coherence between all
possible pairs we noticed that we meet
the striking finding that spike field
coherence differs by tasks and this is
again at baseline and if for such that
spike recurrence is selectively
increased in the fada frequency range
here most increased at five point five
Hertz during a memory task compared to
the categorization task indicating that
this pattern of spike coherence
configures the brain to prepare it to
route memories and to make memory based
decisions and this this pattern of
activity was was pronounced across all a
neurons as shown before but it wasn't
particularly pronounced when we only
look at the memory choice cells in the
categorization choice those that I
showed you before so those cells that
signal choices and so that's what's
shown here where you can see that the
choice cells as a population selectively
increased their spike field coherence
with with the medial temporal lobe local
field potential in two bands in the fade
event but also in the low gamma band and
on the bottom you can see that this is
very specific to due to specific cell
types so if we look at this difference
selectively only for categorization
choice cells that's the green curve so
categorization choice cells phase lock
more during the memory tasks they were
only during fade up where's the memory
choice cells in addition also phase lock
in the GAM event indicating that the
memory choices are special from the
point of view of the inter aerial
connectivity and this pattern of inter
aerial connectivity of the memory choice
cells as the magenta line is indeed
behaviorally relevant is shown here on
the right where if this spike field
coherence is higher during the base
and then the patient is more likely to
make a correct decision for the stimulus
that that will follow so where does this
signal come from how is this network
configured how does it remember what
what task we are in so we discovered
that there is a second type of cell in
on the medial frontal cortex but not in
the MTL which remembers that task we
call those task cells so these cells
have a persistent level of activity
difference throughout the blocks and
they switch their activity not
instantaneously but fairly rapidly
within two to three trials this is shown
at the bottom after one changes the
tasks by instruction so that's a
switching cost and these neurons form
generalizable code in the MFC but not in
the MTL so we hypothesized that these
cells are potentially the source of this
top-down signal that sets up this
network so before I conclude I want to
just very briefly mention two other
interesting pieces of data that we have
started to publish in which are a result
of the consortium one of which is that
we have observed that when we look at
the waveform the XSL waveform of neurons
that we record from relative to the
heartbeat of the patient we have noticed
that they are slight but highly
systematic changes as for example in the
waveform amplitude what's shown here in
the bottom left or the half wave of the
way from you see here the half of in the
amplitude changes slightly but highly
repetitively
as a function of the phase of the
cardiac heartbeat so what we have shown
it now in this paper is that this is a
reflection of slight motion of the brain
relative to the electrode and we have
utilized that slight but repetitive
brain motion to characterize
systematically the extracellular field
and have shown that we can use this
exhaustive measurement of
feel that many positions in space to
more accurately differentiate between
different types of cells and the way we
were able to do that is to use
recordings from human brain slices from
these same cells from which we
characterize the cells
electrophysiological II built a
computational model and indeed virtual
recordings in that computational model
of those human cells and I should say
that this work the second and the third
part of this work was all done at the L
Institute in a collaboration with Costas
Anastasio and lastly I also wanted to
mention that we have just released our
2020 data release which is the first
outcome of our brain initiative
consortium this is a public data release
which consists of 59 subjects and more
than 1,800 neurons during one of the
newel tasks that I have described and it
includes
everything in a standardised neural data
without borders data format as well as
code that shows how to use this data and
we hope that this pipeline will be used
by others in the community to also make
their data available in this
standardized data format so with that
I'm going to conclude and I'm showing
you here a few of the types of cells
that I have described and that we have
worked on so specifically today I talked
about the red cells the memory selective
cells which signal whether stimulus was
seen before or not but not its identity
and I've talked about the blue cells
these are cells which we hypothesize are
integrators and I have shown you that we
believe they are located in medial
frontal cortex and it is these cells
which transiently engage with
hippocampal theta to route information
about memories to the medial frontal
cortex and which then signal choices
memory based choice so the strength of
this work is that it offers us the
opportunity to see both the input to a
decision circuit the evidence which is
the right neurons and something at the
towards the output end of
decision circuit which is the blue
neurons which is a pure choice which is
still in an abstract format so it is not
a modality dependent that I would like
to thank everybody involved in this work
in particular our consortium the
individuals involved you can see listed
here on this slide all the students that
contributed to this work and certainly
our main funder of this work which is
the brain initiative research on humans
consortium thank you thank you very much
Adam and Olli and thanks the organizers
for inviting us to share our work here
I'm gonna be talking about computational
approaches towards understanding
episodic memory we're continuously
bombarded with sensory information if we
take only the visual system as an
example a back-of-the-envelope
calculation indicates that we get about
half the terabyte of information per day
only a small fraction of these gets
crystallized in the form of episodic
memories episodic memories play a
critical role in learning an adaptive
behavior they also are the basic fabric
of who we are and this inability to form
a sonic memory
lead to a large decrease in the quality
of life in order to understand the
mechanisms that give rise to a
consolidation of memories we need to
combine behavior that is understanding
what we remember and what we leave out
we need to understand the neural
circuits that are relevant for forming a
sonic memories and we need to bridge
behavioral neurophysiology through
computational models that will give us
an quantitative understanding and a
predictive understanding of mechanisms
that filter out information and lead to
the formation of episodic memories so
I'd like to tell you today about one
experiment one example of how we are
combining computational work with the
human work and next we have a ga sang
from our group give you a sample of how
we're studying these at the
neurophysiological level so the
experiment is very simple it consists of
two basic steps the first one is where
subjects are watching a 42 minute movie
we're using movies instead of lists of
words or little pictures in order to get
closer to a real life absolute memory
formation so the subjects watch this
42 minute movie and then there's an
interval that can span a couple of days
or a couple of months when with the
behavior experiments in the in the lab
and in the clinical situation
this is either a couple of hours a
couple of days and then after that we
evaluate what subjects recall from the
movie by doing a binary catalyzation
task and recognition tasks where we
present a snapshot from the movie and we
are subjects to indicate yes or no
whether they remember seeing those
particular events and all the events are
intermixed with suitable phones I will
describe in a second so central to our
parsing of the movie is the definition
of a movie cat and a movie shot so cat
is particularly in the movie that's very
different from the previous one as
illustrated in this example here the
interval between two consecutive cuts is
what we define as a shot this typically
has a span of tens of frames which
corresponds to a couple of seconds of
the ratio and these are fundamental to
define events and this in this movie and
then very soon we have GSN
tell us about how important these
banders are in our work the neuro
physiological level so in order to be
able to assess whether people remember a
particular event movie or not we have
foils that are matched to their to be
actual events of the subjects
in terms of color in terms of contrast
in terms of basic visual properties but
to the characters and and and and and
many of the other the duration and other
properties of the shots themselves so
let me give you a quick flavor of the
behavioral data grace of how well people
remember different aspects of the movie
so what you're seeing here is
psychophysics data from 51 subjects each
row corresponds to one subject and I'm
only showing you a very small chunk of
the movie from frame around fifty six
thousand to about fifty seven out of
fifty eight thousand so here each tick
here corresponds to the behavior from
subject one blue corresponds to those
questions that they answer correctly red
corresponds to those cases where the
subjects answered incorrectly so here
are all the responses from the fifty-one
subjects for this particular segment of
the movie so we're probing behavior very
high resolution by integrating weather
such as remember one of these events or
not throughout the entire for the entire
movie so you can see that subjects are
very consistent with each other by
moving your eyes vertically here and
assessing how similar one such place to
another one in terms of the color of the
response so subjects can be consistently
correct or so consistently incorrect but
they are very similar to each other
which helps us define a metric that we
refer to as variability which is
ultimately what dictates what people
remember or not from movie and what
we're going to try to predict using
computational tools so I just showed you
a small segment this is the average
performance and this is here they entire
datasets work on collecting a very high
throughput data set from all the
subjects with very high resolution for
this entire movie so uses the entire
data set for the target I don't and this
is the entire data set of the cable data
for the foil episodes so here we can ask
a couple of questions such as what's the
performance of subjects for when we test
individual shots or even individual
frames as one might expect performance
improves with the duration of the french
people tend to remember better
episodes that are that are longer and
and what's remarkable at the behavioral
level is that subjects and cold on to
these memories for a very long time
people can remember even individual
frames up to a year after the encoding
session we were particularly interested
in here is the ability to build
computational models that will predict
behavior and then we're also going to be
interested in linking this computational
most the neural circuitry underlying
this behavior so to actually understand
how the content of what's happening in
these episodes relates to certain memory
information we use the combination of
computer vision and computational tools
with manual annotations to describe
what's happening at a very hyper
solution throughout the entire movie so
let me give you just one example of that
where we're annotating who's present
which character is present at every
single part of the movie so what we're
seeing here is the entire movie on the
x-axis or the 70,000 frames a movie and
you have each character in the movie on
the right you have the names of all of
these characters and each thick tier
corresponds to when the character shows
up in the color corresponds to whether
it's the front view side view of that
person or give from the back so we have
very detailed annotations now of the
content of the movie here in terms of
which particular characters there but we
also notated a variety of other
information including whether this
action or not in the scene whether their
emotions are not in the scene and for
each one of these variables we can
correlate them with subjects behavior I
won't have time to do justice to each
one of these different annotations but
just let me point to of these so they're
seeing here highlighted are two of these
analysis that we've done on the y-axis
what we have is the performance of
subjects and what you can see is that
those shots that contain action bands
tend to be more memorable and those
shots that are highly ranked in terms of
emotional valence also tend to be more
memorable than those shots that contain
low
emotional maintenance so action and
emotions are two of the more than 100
different types of content-based
annotations that we have a high
resolution for for the movie and can
relate each one of these to the
particular memorability values that are
consistent and across all the different
subjects so we want to build the
computational models that will take all
of this content level and patience be
able to predict memorability so here's
how we're doing that so we take each
shot and from each shot we can construct
a feature vector that contains a
quantitative value representing each one
of these annotations so this feature
vector can contain the presence or
absence of different characters in the
movie this feature vector can also
contain the emotional valence of that
particular shot in the movie it can also
contain with the action or not we can
objects there are whether there is their
sounds and so on so we have a very long
feature back to containing all the
content annotations and then we do that
through all the throbbing terror for the
entire movie and use of this shot is
also associated with a more ability
value with whether the subjects this is
a set of tens of different subjects that
we assessed at the behavioral level
whether they remember that particular
shot or not so now we can use machine
learning to correlate and to understand
the map between these two worlds
understand the bond between the content
information
and memory for each one of these shots
so we train our classifier and then next
we take cross validated data with a
color person movie that were not used
during the painting and wait for any one
individual shot that is for a couple of
seconds duration in in movie weather
subjects will or will not remember any
one particular event so let me give you
a flavor and now for how that works to
include with this presentation so here
what I'm showing you on the y-axis is
the classification accuracy and we're
seeing here on the x-axis is the subject
number for 41 subjects where we tested
this business procedure so here we are
testing at the individual subject level
and at the individual short level
whether we can predict what each person
is going to is going to remember or not
from the from the movie events so these
are binary choices so chance corresponds
to 50 percent so we see that on average
we get a little bit over 70 percent
performance in predicting mobility at a
single subject and single shot level as
you can see there's a lot of Turgeon ad
over subjects importantly we didn't
train the classifier individually for
each subject we're only training it for
the average memorability across the
different across all the different
subjects so there is no more ability
across different subjects but overall we
can we can predict a reasonably well and
sewing well above chance even with a
very small set of content based on
intonations what's what's going to be
memorable and what's not going to be
memo so I'm going to take a step back
now to conclude and go back to the
notion that understanding of serving
memory requires combining behavior
neurophysiology and computational models
we're going to tell you more about the
neurophysiological aspects next but this
link between understanding what the
problem is about that is the formation
of episodic memories understand the
neural circuit and they will attempt to
be able to build completion models that
bridge between the two it is going to be
crucial to really build a mechanistic
model of memory formation and in the
future help alleviate problems with
those people who cannot consolidate
memories this effort takes a village
we need to collect an extensive amount
of data both at the behavioral level at
the neurophysiological level and
therefore being part of this consortium
and being part of this amazing group of
people is central in terms of the types
of skills that are combined here but
also in terms of the multi center
approach to collect this type of very
hard to get village
Recordings that we're going to discuss
next our initial work suggests that we
can study short memory formations in
close to real-life scenarios and that
the completion model can predict no more
ability even in single events so now
we're ready to examine the neural
circuits and therefore immune to pass
the baton on to GSM who will tell you
about what happens inside brain when
people are performing at suck memories
thank you very much hello everyone I'm
Gia I'm in a postdoc from dr. Raymond
and dr. Rudi Shasta's lab so first I
want to thank lab roots for the
invitation for giving me such great
opportunity so I can be here to share
some of the results from one of our
projects that were supported by the NIH
brain initiative and as Abril described
this project specifically focusing on
study the role of offend boundaries in
segmenting episodic memories so as we
are now our daily life unfolds over time
however the member of such continuous
information doesn't necessarily stored
as a gigantic piece but instead our
brain actually automatically detect or
segments such continuous information
into discrete events so later on such
discrete events can be served as
building blocks which can be recombined
or reconfigured for different goals so
to study such event segmentation
phenomenon EPOS behavior and also
neuronal level we performed memory tasks
on patients with epilepsy and while
their brains were implying it was
electrodes when they first stay at the
hospital for potential surgical
evaluations so the memory task consists
of two phases and during the encoding
phase we presented a series of clips
without any audio sounds to the subjects
and to ensure their active involvement
also there are some true or false
questions related to the clips will
presented random
while they were watching the clip and
the key manipulation here is we amended
different kind of boundaries in the
clips and as show here in the slide
there are examples showing three
different kind of boundaries we were
using and in the original experiment and
so for the no boundary conditions it's
literally a continuous shot from one
specific movie and also for the saw
boundaries it refers to those movie cuts
that helps the same transitioning within
the same movie and for the hot
boundaries we manually create it by
putting two different clips from two
different movies together so both soft
and hop on Dre's contains such transient
change of the future features but only
the ha boundary case contains the link
discontinuity of the narrative stories
so as you may know it is already since
there's no real boundaries in the no
boundary conditions we manually define a
virtual boundary which is approximately
the middle of the clip as the virtual
component boundaries in the non boundary
condition just for the computers and
with to the other cases for the later
analysis so after the subjects watch all
the clips we evaluate the subjects
memory of each clip in two different
ways first we evaluate subjects clip
remember the clip content in the scene
recognition basically we extract the
static frames from the clips they have
seen before and the clips they haven't
seen before and ask them to decide
whether that's old or new frames and we
also evaluate subjects memory of the
temporal relationship of that clips so
basically we take two frames from the
same clip and place them side-by-side
and ask the subject to decide whether
the left or the right frames happens
first in the original clip and besides
the binary choice we also measure
subjects confidence levels so if Eve us
the information of subjects memory
quality and also provides the
opportunity for us to study the
show interactions between a boundary and
subjects confidence level so at the
behavioral level we observe some
boundary effects in the senior clinician
things the temporal distance between the
target frame and also different kind of
boundaries barriers so if we groups of
trials based on the relative distance to
the proceeding boundaries we actually
observed increased recognition
accuracies for the fringe right after
boundary relative to the friends that
are far away from the boundaries and we
don't see this kind of distance effects
actually in the no boundary conditions
and besides that we also observe some
boundary effects in the temporal
discrimination task and the boundaries
is definitely affect subjects behavior
outcomes in terms of the accuracy rate
and the response time and also the
confidence levels so forth no boundary
and South boundary case we don't see any
behavior difference between them but for
the hot boundary case we observe that
subjects tend to have lower
discrimination accuracy rates and it
takes a long time for them to recall the
temporal order and they also have like
in last confidence when they try to
recall the temporal order of two frames
that will originally separate it by the
hot boundary so building pound such
behavior in fact we also try to look
into the brain and to see what our
neural dynamics changes when
encountering different kind of
boundaries so to address that we record
a single unit activities from different
brain regions and thanks to the set up
from this kind of collaborative
consortiums we were able to record it
approximately a thousand neurons within
a year at different brain regions and
the results that I'm gonna present it
later will be the neurodynamics mailing
from the hippocampus amygdala and pure
hippocampus dryers which are the
critical structures from the middle
temporal lobe that facilitates the
episodic memories so as I mentioned
before during the encoding we have
different or we invent a different kind
of
during click display so for each neurons
we can presumably project its activation
patterns into this to the plots with the
x-axis indicating the time and the
y-axis refers either the trial number or
the firing rates and also we can align
such neural activities aligned to the
boundaries so we can study the relative
change of the neural activity relative
to the boundaries so as show here is the
example of how that looks so in this
plot for each dot represents two
activation of that specific neurons and
the colors indicates different kind of
boundaries as you can see here this
neurons increase its firing rate right
after the boundary on set and also
regardless whether it's a soft boundary
and hot boundaries and this type of
boundary cells we found it all three
regions and the majority of them are
from the period camera tires
now interestingly the majority of this
kind of boundary cells don't respond to
the stem I onset which indicates that
such increased firing rate patterns
presumably might be driven by some
higher level current functions is there
just purely detection of the visual
change so also we found for this kind of
line bound ourselves some of them
carries some memory effects so if we
group the trials based on the subjects
subsequent memory performance during the
scene recognition then we can see that
this kind of increased the firing rate
mainly during a boundary correct and
also soft boundary correct trials but
not in the incorrect trials which means
um the responses trends of this type of
neurons actually during the encoding can
actually predict subjects of performance
during the senior clinician and besides
the boundary cells we also observe
another cell types that signaling the
boundaries as well so here is another
example showing this cell increases
firing rate right after the boundary but
this time it only increases firing rate
the hot boundary but not the soft
boundary and this ha boundary cells
located in all three regions as well but
mainly from the hippocampus and again
all this neurons don't response to a
stimuli onset and some of them nuanced
there are neuron activities during the
time for discrimination tasks also have
the boundary effects so if we right now
group their trials based on different
boundary conditions and also their
behavior outcomes during the same
temporal discrimination caste then align
their activity to the bottom press so we
can see there's a increase the firing
rate before the bottom press but only
when a subject quickly recall the
temporal order of touch and frames were
originally separated by the ha boundary
which is the green dots here so besides
this to interesting population of
neurons signaling different kind of
boundaries we also wondered whether at
the population level the neural stage
changes when a crossing or when
encountering different kind of
boundaries as well to address that
question we've formed a neuronal dynamic
matrices which using the firing rate
from the pseudo population of all Middle
Temple cells here and then we project
such higher dimensional informations
into a lower dimensional space which
carries the information for three
different type of three different type
of boundaries using the methods called
de mixing principle component analysis
and now the neural state can at each
time point it can be projected into this
lower dimensional space as one dot and
when with applying a sliding window
we were able to see a trajectory of this
neural state shift and as you can see
during the fixation periods all these
three boundary conditions trajectory
doesn't different differentiate from
each other but while we play in the clip
we can observe such differentiation
starts and
you may also notice that during the high
bondrée display there's a transient your
state shift which marketing as the black
dodge here but we can quantify such
neural state shift by computing the
Euclidean distance in such lower
dimensional space and by applying the
sliding window we were able to plot such
your entire state shift as a function of
time so as shown in the figure here
each y represents to the neuro states
shift for each condition bound for each
boundary conditions and we observed this
large nurse day shift
for only the ha boundary case right
after the boundary onset but not the
other two boundary conditions and
interestingly when we even include
excluding excluding the Habanera cells
we still observed such newer states
shift and when we compare in these two
conditions we do observe a slightly
delayed in your state shift occurs so
which indicating that maybe the event
segmentation is initiated by the
harbinger cells and down streaming some
information to the other populations of
cells in the middle campbellot to
initiate a different neural state for
the upcoming event so since we observe
this transient neuro state shift around
the boundaries we wonder what police
with subjects memory performance so if
we group the trials based on subjects
memory performance in the temporal
discrimination task we have served
longer or a larger neuro state shift in
the incorrect trials compared to the
correct trials which indicates that and
the difficulty of recalling the temporal
order of two friends or of the two
events associated with the original
encoding neuro States distance so in
summary at the behavioral level we
observed that bond raised either
enhanced the recognition accuracy will
have andresen clears the memory of the
temporal orders
and at the neuronal level we observed
this two population of neurons signaling
a different kind of boundary signals
either response to only the Habanera
were both soft and hop on trees and also
some of these neurons responses trends
correlates with subjects memory
performance and in addition at the
population levels we observe this larger
neural state shift when encountering the
ha boundaries which are negatively
correlated with subjects temporal
discrimination accuracy so in the end I
want to thank both my pis and my
collaborators and lab mates from also in
recording sites the lovely patients and
also again the funding source and I
bring initiative for supporting us
building such one of our team especially
as a postdoc it benefits me a lot by
working under such collaborative
environment specifically since
everyone's have slightly different
backgrounds I constantly get some
feedbacks from these different
perspectives and also the sharing
cultures in the consortium is really
helpful which speeds up my learning
curves during my postdoc fellowship
training thank you so much